تذكر عندما لم تتوقف Spring Breakers في فلوريدا عن الحفلات حتى بعد أن ضرب جائحة فيروس كورونا الولايات المتحدة ، فما حدث عندما انتهت عطلة الربيع ، يمكننا في الواقع تتبع حركة هذه الأجهزة خلال الأسابيع المتبقية من شهر مارس لمعرفة أين ذهبت هذه الأجهزة بعد Spring Breakers تركت الشاطئ ، فما تشاهده في هذا الفيديو هو ما يحدث إذا لم يمارس الناس التباعد الاجتماعي حيث تجمع مجموعة من الأفراد الذين تعرفهم أو بضعة آلاف من الأشخاص في هذه الحالة على شاطئ في فورت لودرديل فلوريدا وجميع الأماكن العميقة السفر الذي يعرض مدى الترابط بين عالمنا هو أن جوش أنتون يدير وضع x-mode ، وهي شركة تتعقب حركة الأجهزة مثل الهواتف المحمولة ، ويقول فريقه إنها تستخدم بيانات الموقع لتتبع أين ذهب كل شخص على الشاطئ في فورت لودرديل في مارس بعد يوم غادر بما في ذلك تلك Spring Breakers من نيويورك إلى الغرب الأوسط ، حتى كندا ، أنت تعرف قوة بيانات الموقع هذه التي يمكن استخدامها لفهمك ليس فقط.  الآن كيف يمكن للأشخاص والأماكن التي
يسافرون إليها بعد التجمع ولكن من
المحتمل أيضًا أن تستعد وأن تكون
استباقيًا ، يحدث شيء من
الصواب ولكن تحديد النقاط الساخنة المستقبلية
حيث يمكن أن تحدث حرائق crota قبل
حدوثها ولكن تطبيقات
تقنية أوضاع X تسير على ما يرام
يقول أنطون إن الشركة تتعقب 25
مليون جهاز شهريًا في
الولايات المتحدة وملايين آخرين
حول العالم ، تقول X-mode إنها
مستعدة للعمل مع الحكومات
والمجموعات الأخرى للمساعدة في وقف انتشار
فيروس كورونا الذي نعمل معه  أنت تعرف
التطبيقات التي تستخدم موقعًا حقيقيًا
لحالة الاستخدام لتشغيل الموقع سواء
كانت تطبيقات نقل سواء كانت
تطبيقات الطقس أو التطبيقات التي تنبهك بشأن
الزلازل التي تحدث هناك ،
ثم نقوم بدمج تقنية الموقع لدينا
للسماح بمشاركة البيانات حيث
يمكن للمستخدم الاشتراك  لمشاركة بيانات الموقع الخاصة بهم ،
فإننا نلتزم بـ gdpr ، فنحن
نمتثل لـ
CCPA ولكننا نحاول أن نتخطى ذلك وهو
ما تعرفه  ما نسميه الخصوصية
مدركًا لمطالبات الشركة
وتراخيصها بأن البيانات لأطراف ثالثة
بما في ذلك المعلنين الذين
ليس لديهم أي معلومات تعريف شخصية
يمكن أن تستخدم
تقنيتك لتتبع الأفراد يمكن أن تجذبني ، فقد
يكون من الصواب أننا لا نسمح بعدم
السماح بأي من  شركاء للقيام بذلك
لأننا لا نعتقد أن هذا هو
الشيء الصحيح الذي يجب القيام به بشكل جيد ، يقول أنطون إن
شركته تبذل قصارى جهدها للحفاظ على
أمان البيانات ولا تحدد
مالكي الأجهزة التي تتعقبها ، فهناك
مخاوف جدية تتعلق بالخصوصية بشأن هذا النوع
للتكنولوجيا في عام 2018 ، أظهر تحقيق أجرته صحيفة New York Times
كيف
يمكن استخدام بيانات الموقع لتحديد
المالك المحدد لجهاز معين تعرفه ،
ولا أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس يدركون أنه
حتى هذه التكنولوجيا
موجودة ، وأعتقد أن البعض  يتسلل الناس إلى
حد بعيد عما يمكن أن تقوله
للأشخاص الذين لديهم مخاوف عندما
يرون نوعًا ما أنه يمكنك تتبع أجهزة
مثل هذه ، سأقتبس من العم
بن  pider-man وهو ما
تأتي به القوة العظيمة المسؤولية الكبيرة ، كما
تعلم ، أعتقد أن هناك خطًا رفيعًا أعتقد
أنه من المهم جدًا أن
توافق على هذا فقط ومن المهم جدًا
أن تعود عند غراء تلك
البيانات
[موسيقى]